what's happening right now is very
striking
this is the first time really that
Israeli leadership has openly uh broken
with U.S leadership the new
Administration especially the leading
figures like Ben Veer and smokers are
simply telling the United States get
lost Netanyahu has made pretty strong
statements saying we're a Southern
Country will do what we want we don't
care what you say it's the first time
the confrontation has been this clear
and it's not clear how the United States
will respond for the first time ever or
three years ago an American a U.S
representative in the House of
Representatives
introduced legislation bowling for the
United States to
reconsider U.S Aid in Israel in the
light of U.S law well I think all of
these things are moving to the fore
could lead to big changes in the future
it is based to a large extent on
substantial shifts in public opinion
foreign